foreign
[Music]
a young hip neighborhood known for
trendy shops and restaurants in 2010
Allen and Jen saffron opened a
restaurant called The Burger Kitchen
good evening welcome to Burger Kitchen
my name is Alan thank you for coming
Allen's always had the dream to run a
restaurant because he's always enjoyed
meats you do the cheese in the middle
you seal the beef and then you do the
cheese on the top that's what the
ultimate cheeseburger is I have really
eaten meat all my life I've eaten in
hundreds of different steak restaurants
and then I figured I'll try and get into
a hamburger restaurant but we didn't
have the money to open up the best
burger in L.A and I took the money from
my son Daniel I was kind of dragged into
this I got a sizable inheritance from my
grandfather there was money in a trust
account and my dad took 250 000 of my
money to put it into this restaurant hey
guys how you doing because of that I had
to make the place work but my dad is not
running burgers all of our burgers are a
prime weigu that's the best meat you can
buy in the country I've now changed our
standard Burgers all to Australian wager
it's all Frozen we take it out of the
freezer I mean it sucks so dude I know
it's like really dry throw that out my
God man when you buy your fatties
pre-made and they're dry and you know
it's not good but you continually say it
is because you don't have any taste buds
really not good
Burger Kitchen is managed by a
dysfunctional family you got three
Chiefs and about four Indians today
there's a lot of tension within all the
family members which filters down to us
of course I happen to order a sweet
potato fries and I have two tickets
you need to listen to me it's hard to be
belittled every day so for me to come to
work now is like almost unbearable David
all hand then you can come back and
expedite okay you can expedite nothing
thank you it is such a chaotic work
environment with Alan Jen Daniel is he
doing a natural for 45 yes he is doing a
natural for 44. it is just a train wreck
and a half I can organize the tickets I
don't know why they can't get it through
their [__] skulls okay all right
relax I did not picture myself doing
this but these are the cards have been
dealt and I want to make it a success
table 11
my father he does not treat me as an
equal partner he still treats me like a
child it's very infuriating please help
me please
I am absolutely at the end of my rope I
don't have anyone to lean on I really
don't Chef Ramsay is our last hope
[Music]
what an amazing place of a restaurant to
smack bang in the middle of Los Angeles
although you're concerned wow
[Music]
nice hello good morning how are you Alan
Safran how are you Alan good to see you
thank you very much this is my wife Chad
when Chef Ramsay arrived and it just
blew my mind let's sit down have a a
chat shall we yes I mean we've got Chef
Ramsay in here to improve us
otherwise
[Music]
um how long have you been open 16 months
so 16 months ago yeah so it just opened
yes is the business making money no
we're losing 5 000 up to six thousand a
month every month
wow wow wow
how can it go so wrong I I think it was
a combination of a lot of things that I
think we did wrong I think we changed
the menu many to too many times how many
times have you changed the menu probably
10. 10 times yeah that's nearly once a
month what about the chef I mean
normally a menu changer when the chefs
change how many children
10 as well yes front of house being as
bad yeah we've been for about 20 service
10 menus
10 chefs
20 servers
what's going wrong
Yelp there's killed us
the office crashed us terribly they're
also deleting five-star reviews oh come
on I can prove it I could show you right
on the hill
is there a plot against you from Yale to
close this business no question in my
mind oh Alan come on you've been
watching too many [__] bomb movies
so
um opening restaurants in La is pretty
expensive where'd the money come from
Alan had about 250 000 that he inherited
from his dad okay nice so he put all
that money into it and then we started
running out of money and in order to
open my husband went to my son and now
my son Daniel is in for another I think
over 250 000 as well because he
inherited some money too I I was
managing his money so I actually took
part of that money and as the manager of
his funds you then invested in the
business yes
did your son Daniel know well of course
you knew eventually
[Music]
we say eventually I told him after the
fact what I kind of forced him into it
by taking his money
[Music]
seriously
there's Daniel here he's in the business
he does the nighttime [__] okay you work
in the daytime daytime and you don't
work together uh not really that much
our heads log together right my son has
a great deal of resentment towards me
and I don't know why
what about the food I think it's pretty
damn good now yes I'd say it's four to
five stars four to five stars so you're
one star out okay I can't wait to taste
it we've got the background thank you I
appreciate it okay thank you Chef Ramsay
will love my Burgers without a shadow of
a doubt
I'm Marilyn Mary's nice to see you
first off what's wrong with the
restrooms there's lack of management and
burgers they're never cooked right
they're always sent back wow yeah
I tell people that I'm sorry probably 15
times a night there's no consistency
whatsoever and that's wearing on me like
as a person I go home and I'm like oh I
feel so guilty for serving bad food okay
let's start off I'm in California so
let's go for California and how would
you like it medium rare please thank you
okay
okay gotta see the Australian meat pie
yeah obviously I'll have to go for the
award-winning bro okay yeah I think
we're done thank you I'm good thank you
good to see you too
dirty Place guys come on
okay this is a lot of food at first I
loved working at Burger Kitchen but all
I'm doing now slide in with the
management I'll handle this Jen I want
you to get out of the way right now it's
a runaway restaurant I have no control
13 said their burgers
yes anything you have to say go through
me yeah
Chef David does not like me he doesn't
want me in the kitchen oh my God that
woman
and he tends to gossip and blame me for
a lot that's going on out walks the
Diabla we've made some errors here in
Staffing this is like a green ring
circus Chef Ramsay I noticed you ordered
the cowboy that'll take a little longer
don't you work I'm the one that's a one
pound burger
lovely
chef David Blaine yes what the magician
no no he's not the magician right he's
just coincidentally the same name he was
the head pastry chef at the Peninsula
hotel now he's the executive chef of the
burger restaurant yes David Copperfield
you dessert Chef now
David he was like Chef David Blaine like
the magician
too well I can't disappear from here
when I came in here I wasn't I wasn't
allowed to do any of my recipes I had to
do exactly without what I told me to do
that's the California even if I knew it
was wrong I still had to do it this is
the California Burger wow thank you
okay California Burger I better let you
eat yes I'll leave you to it thank you
rare it's raw
[Music]
Bread's just sweet sweet and doughy
Bland tasteless raw meat no flavor
wow that's nasty how are you doing yeah
into the kitchen cooking season
um I know they throw a little bit of
salt in well don't be blind because
they're mixing it
I mean what's wrong with this one
stop stop stop what's wrong with that
one so stay
it's one of the best burgers I've ever
tasted in my life so it's very
disappointing because it's a natural
natural with white cheddar yes
how was it cooked what do you ask for no
that's good medium rare oh we're good on
it yeah and this one is natural with
white cheddar oh this is award-winning
yeah great thank you
[Music]
wow wow
that's the award-winning Burger
shocking
silent
I know I asked for it mid-rare but
that's the first to me this is raw
yeah it is rough
I can't believe that my burger was that
bad that is just shocking
I don't know what to think anymore isn't
this natural it's raw in the middle
oh come on guys what the [__] is that I
was shocked that it was undercooked
because I okayed the burger but you know
we were under a lot of stress okay
because this is really bad but instead
of looking at the own deficiencies they
wanted to put it on me I'm about done
with Charles [__] in here man I added
his domain here 100 I am their scapegoat
I'm about to blow up
Jeff Ramsay had a horrendous start to
his lunch
and after sending another raw Burger
back to the kitchen David this is really
bad I'm about done with all the [__]
here man wow I out of here
Chef David Blaine wants to disappear
about to blow up people are crazy I
laughed out of frustration but when I
came on I made it do it with my staff to
stay
I keep my word and that's what I'm doing
let's do this okay we got the big Cowboy
Burger medium rare if we don't have
extra big buttons
oh this is going to be interesting we
got the cowboy done I'm terrified to
bring out of this burger I don't even
think he could swallow I need your ride
here is the cowboy Burger
cowboy
with a very small hat on top look at the
bun where'd you start
[Music]
honestly look at that
come on seriously
you'd expect a decent button
this is a bland
greasy cooked to him
that is Dreadful football I'm sorry like
it's not your fault wow
I was shocked disappointed embarrassed
good
Steve pies up guys but one thing I have
that's a little different is an
Australian meat pie the Australian meat
pie is the number one Staple in
Australia I have brought them to America
and Chef Ramsay will absolutely love it
that's Ramses by the way
she's not gonna like it
so this is the the Australian meat pie
the beef
time to go down under is that thing
[Music]
I mean that's disgusting that Australian
pie can [__] off back to Australia with
pleasure
the raw doughy pastry on top and Soggy
gooey stuff on the bottom one word for
this meow cat food the disgusting didn't
like nothing at all in that thing
it's everything I believe Chef David
hand handled the menu he's not an
executive chef as he claims we didn't do
good he's a pastry chef
wow
well that was a uh I've no let's meet
the team this is uh Chef David this is
the executive chef David how are you
David Blaine right the magician wow show
me the work your magic today this is
jalapeno jalapeno okay great David that
was [__] hideous
everything I've tasted has been nasty
awful Bland and you watched all that
coming out or did you cook any of it I
helped cook everything and you can't
work your magic on a burger
seriously you get paid as an executive
chef wow what's funny now is this an ego
massage for you
I follow the recipes as I am told by the
owners and if I try to change the
recipes I am passed out of here what
it's not quite sure
man up and drink it again drinking again
my husband doesn't drink I don't know I
don't know I can't get the truth out of
anybody here explain this to me Jen he
does have a lot of control in the
kitchen that's not true Chef what about
the mushrooms and you change the whole
recipe and you added what you want salt
on the mushrooms let's tell the truth
did you add wine to the mushroom recipe
that's how you make saute restaurants I
just asked a question did you add one
yes ma'am you didn't tell anyone that
you added wine to the mushrooms how do
you missing the points you're focusing
on a mushroom mushrooms are important to
me I'm from Poland I think of all the
problem is instead of putting sugar in
that coffee putting little Prozac in it
David I just want the truth this is the
truth I would be better off as a brain
surge than you run in this restaurant
after Chef Ramsay was served raw and
tasteless Burgers
Jan and Chef David can't seem to agree
on who has control of the kitchen I
follow the recipes as I have told what
about the mushrooms and you changed the
whole recipe and you added why didn't
you want salt on the mushrooms and it's
starting to get personal okay let's get
down to where it's supposed to be the
way you treat us the way you're
manipulated and the way I had to buy
groceries this morning where's my money
for my groceries that you own me now
first of all my son you haven't paid me
my son was wired this morning
we don't do that David I come in here
and I work I open the place I do what
I'm supposed to and I don't get paid
where's my paycheck that's nice I have
checks written out to your wife he has
been working on uh the spirit of getting
paid the spirit and I will see him
because this sounds crazy where's Jim
gun she's right and get checks all of a
sudden
how do you missing the point don't
concentrate on the check I said I'm
going to pay him that's all that's
important I feel I'm a little bit sort
of in a Land of loopy Loops you see how
much bullshits flying around here your
chef says the egg is forced to follow
your recipes
let's see what it can come up with do me
a favor get out there now go and get
some beef pate and cook me a burger a
burger yourself both to get out there
bye guys this is my career this is what
I love to do I'm smart enough to know
that he's gonna like my burger that Jim
is a liar dude she can't tell the truth
this is crazy the whole place should be
on [__] LSD man okay I need to taste
what this guy can cook yes
Jen and David do not get along that well
he's very opinionated and that's
difficult for my wife
attacked me I know that stand up for
your wife
I am standing up for you but I'm
realizing how difficult our situation is
while Chef David shops for ingredients
for his Burger
Jeff Ramsey decides to visit Daniel to
get his perspective on the issues at
Burger Kitchen
Hi how are you good good to see you
hanging in there hanging in there yeah
there's a nice little cozy Place yeah
how long have you been in here five
years five years yeah five years I've
lived with Wendy for three she is my
girlfriend okay Wendy likewise good to
see you too what does Wendy do I go in
when he's there only at night and
they're not there she comes in well sit
down let's have a let's have a chat
there was a falling out between Wendy
and my family my dad doesn't respect her
and I don't know why take me back to the
beginning
when you invested in this restaurant
unknown to you yeah how frustrating was
that Mary your dad was handling you
money it was in a trust account right
that he had access to how did we get in
this situation my dad and all this
wisdom in the way you can just
manipulate said you know why don't we
open a restaurant and I said well that's
a little ridiculous you know we know
nothing about it let's not do that how
much does it take 250 000. wow I was
infuriated well did you do this you know
without even my approval and he's like I
thought you'd like it are you kidding me
ridiculous it's your money
yeah I know what's the relationship with
your father like now how did you get on
it's not good no I mean I can feel that
when was the last time you actually made
a decision together
never my dad still treats me like a
child it almost makes me want to cry he
changes the menu way too often and he
doesn't tell anyone 10 menus four over
twenty over 20 different menu changes
wow I I can't get even on the books I'm
not even on the records you know I've
asked him numerous times I've asked the
accountant this is like three months ago
this is the only [__] proof I have
which is a joke this was to placate me
when the restaurant first opened that
was that's a joke that's not true this
is printed out on a computer
by the way this is nothing this is not
this is toilet paper I thought it was
gonna be bad but I didn't think it was
gonna be quite that bad I just I don't
trust them anymore it's taken a while
for me to kind of like come to that
um realization you know but
um
sorry
it's hard you know it's hard to watch
this happen it's hard to watch somebody
get beaten down so much the fight is no
longer there
okay uh well that's gonna be a even
deeper Insight run it as normal tonight
yeah and just pretend I'm not there but
I'll be in and out yeah watching
everything yeah okay okay good to meet
you both thank you okay thank you again
thank you see you later tonight bye
thank you very much
[Music]
back at the restaurant David is
preparing Chef Ramsay's Burger let's
call this one the Redemption murder and
for the first time since he started
working at the restaurant he is using
his own recipe but this time I want a
season our way this is very important to
me that when I make this burger it's a
good burger but at least it's going to
be my burger and it's not going to be
gin and Allen's Burger
let's start getting this thing ready
you making them a burger too yeah with
the Wago
a lot with the way it goes I'm smart
enough to listen to what Chef Ramsay
wanted he wants a nice juicy burger he
wants something with flavor not frozen
meat
medium rare brother okay get it off
we're ready
give Ramsay a hamburger man here we go I
know if you do eating lunch don't worry
please I just made a burger my
ingredients your own ingredients yes wow
so it's not on the menu now do you want
to try it some people have called me a
meat sculpture or a meat Creator a lot
of different celebrities have eaten my
food and have said it was fantastic yes
you'll see yeah I'll try it I can see
the blood but what's in there it's the
uh wagoon mix but I've what I've done is
I've had certain spices and I've made a
cheeseburger I don't like a man Alan
you're not at me the expert you don't
know a thing about me the only thing you
know how to do is sit on the computer in
there and change menus that's what you
do
and you made this yes it's amazing
that
that is hideous
at least it's seasoned this is the
Burger I'm dying for David please
presentation it looks great thank you
Chef explain please I'm using a small
gruyere with grilled tomato spring mix
with a mustard aioli and a jumbo pickle
homemade what I had earlier this is this
looks night and day wow okay
bloody hell I mean that's what I call a
burger
and how does it taste
[Music]
you chef the temperature's perfect and
the roll is crispy yeah sure would you
like to have a little taste I'd love to
[Music]
what is that stronger taste that I'm
tasting gruya cheese and it's smoked
right yes yeah I love it does that go
through the meat I taste something
stronger in there like a dry aged or
something beef
but I do like my meat red in it I am a
medium rare girl problem is that's not
medium rare as it should be it may be
medium but I can tell you what it's
bloody juicy
that is delicious yeah I'd give that
nine out of ten love that title there by
the way Redemption burger and you
certainly did that suck on this burger
Jen and you too Alan
why aren't we serving Burgers like that
because I thought the wagyu meat was
better you've got your priorities wrong
because of the word wagyu sounds
glamorous and expensive it doesn't mean
you say it's gonna deliver you the most
tastiest burger my question to you is
that if you know that your burgers are
better than what you're cooking
currently what the [__] are you doing
I'm forced into making what they like me
to make right if I try to do a change
I'm persecuted for it to make a good
change he wants to blame me for
everything in the kitchen and I'm not
that
saying how am I that powerful do you see
a chef hat on me you see me swirling the
pans and making the Patties or chopping
the mushrooms or putting the salt on I
mean what really frustrates me is the
fact that I get to served that mediocre
crap and that thing is seasoned
beautifully cheese gives it a little bit
of saltiness
absolutely delicious I think you should
Jen whatever
Jen where's she going this is ridiculous
thank you
David has proven to Chef Ramsay that
thing is season abuse me absolutely
delicious he can cook a winning Burger
when he is not confined by Jen and
Allen's recipes
but the chef's success doesn't appear to
be appreciated by one of the owners Jen
Jen come on
question
thank you Jen got up from the tasting
because Jen wanted me to be the reason
that their pitiful restaurant hasn't
made it Jen what's the matter what's
wrong
I'm 64 years old I've I've been through
many many different situations my
situation is to get
together
it's not about some bully or some fool
is that why you just walked out because
my heart hurt what do I do is that a
false thing if I have to sit there and
smile and say that that everything is
fine I can't do that nobody used to tell
me what's going on that's all I'm facing
a bully who has been abusive to me who's
we need to address this but just for you
to get up and walk out it just looks a
little bit weird I need you and I think
more importantly I think Alan does
yeah okay please come on okay I feel a
good energy from Chef Ramsay if I was
here to be in a positive place I felt
very comfortable in coming back
okay Jen's back founder uh yes you got a
little bit upset and she was uh I
understand well because I I know that
the chef can deliver this kind of uh
and should have delivered it before why
did Jin just walk out the back door
that was a different issue that's
another issue
say nasty things to me let me explain
something I don't care what you said
take it easy eight to 12 chefs walk out
since the day I walked in here you want
me to fail I think that woman's shocked
if you get in the water with him you
might get your testicles a bit off the
reason you walked out the back door is
because you wanted Chef Francis
stop stop there two seconds I want to
say place in operation you running your
job watching you do your job and you run
in the kitchen
service we'll talk after that okay
delicious thank you let's go
as the staff prepares for dinner service
one other thing Alan is something he
wants to share with Chef Ramsay I'd like
to give you my book you've got your own
cookbook I wrote a book
yeah I read a book gentle Satan it was
about my father my that's what my mother
called him is that you on the cover
there that's my father that's your
father that's me did you have a bad
relationship with him yeah because 34
years ago he wanted me to stay in
Australia and be in his business and I
said dad I don't want to be in their
business plus I've met a wonderful girl
in New York I want to move there I said
if you leave Australia it'll be the end
of us forever you didn't want to be
controlled right I didn't want to be
control did you love him
say it's a love-hate relationship how
can you
I'm someone who stabbed you so much in
the back and to think that a father
would do that to his own son
is beyond shocking um it sounds like a
killing race
thank you very much bedtime reading
thank you I'll see you later
[Music]
welcome to Burger Kitchen my name is
Alan I'm the owner thank you for coming
from the moment Chef Ramsay arrived he
has been hit with a variety of issues
it's now time for dinner service one two
three let's go
go okay all right okay good and for the
first time in a long time Daniel will be
working alongside his father and mother
all right what can I get you can I get a
Texas
sure how do you want to cook media
please okay Texas Chili
bar do that you got your two tickets all
right so two Texas two one Texas Chili
that's it just one Alejandro Texas chili
burger medium hey what are you actually
what are you doing tonight I've been
hosting Expediting serving good a lot so
your father taking orders as well no
he's just hosting okay I don't want him
to do I've been wanting to just stay by
the register yeah and just run bills he
doesn't like listening does it no one
likes to see it that beer is rated in
the top 10 in California by the leading
beer editor excellent beer I didn't want
my dad to be host again yes a breath
problem he does have bad breath he walks
around with bad breath and I know I know
for a fact I've seen it some of the
customers when he starts talking they
lean back every beer that's just
come on
doesn't listen doesn't listen okay Danny
do you mind if I see you in my office I
did I'm not talking to you just for a
second all I did was greet people that's
fine I didn't do anything else I know
okay so listen I'm happy to take that
role I don't need any other fine then
greet and then don't lay her on the
tables I won't linger you're mistaken
about my your mistake Alan and Daniel
never worked together
and yell the relationship is that
fragmented no it's just it's just how it
is Daniel's dad doesn't listen no matter
how hard you fight he doesn't understand
the word no he just does it he doesn't
listen to Danny all right so where we
are we're okay I can't do these tickets
like this there's not no room for him
all right it's okay okay I'll help you
I'll help you I'll help you I'm waiting
for a breakfast that's what turkey meat
is that breakfast turkey yes no that's a
god box okay hold on hold on
sorry I don't need you to second
guessing me Oscar I'm not I'm not going
to
despite all the confusion in the kitchen
let's go guys pick it up burgers are
being sent out quickly got a breakfast
burger here but that doesn't mean the
customers are satisfied with their meals
yeah it's really mushy oh okay and his
dinner service continues
so does the pattern of unhappy customers
I said medium well okay all right this
is not medium well I'm sorry about that
oh [__] medium well that's not a medium
well guys this isn't a medium well and
frequent returns to the kitchen table
52. this was not supposed to be a junior
cheeseburger I'm not gonna say that the
food isn't the problem but the entire
ticket system is messed up it's total
chaos let me show you something what
does it say it says Junior version okay
that's a junior cheeseburger with fries
let's go with it
what's really screwed up is the ticket
system
right now I'm talking about your ticket
system you have the carbons here the
order comes out you give the carbon to
the waiter they take it to the table
that's it final done simple you know I
don't know let me run it I can run it
then
you can go behind there and I'll run it
all right okay
David doesn't even know what the [__]
he's doing he looks like a deer in
headlights the trained monkey could take
tickets and get them out on time that's
nothing I've never seen a family so
worth it being thrown under a bus no
one's being thrown under a bus here man
thank you very much you're welcome
what in the [__] is all this for always
tickets
this it's like a game of Solitaire is
this what it's like normal yes I think
this place needs help so bad but the
ticketing process it's hard for the
kitchen to really take time and focus on
every burger and make it the best table
two do they have their fries table two
there is no table too table [__] two
Jesus guys
[Music]
that's 42. there's two guests
you're [__] did I say table two it says
42. there's two people table two's not
gonna have 42 [__] gas
I'm gonna jump on this side and say you
knock your ass out of you know
come here right now man come here right
now
get out of here he wants to [__]
fight me you want to threaten me you
want to threaten me get the [__] out
right now yeah get out right now right
now get the [__] out right there now out
get up done you're done I'm done done
all right goodbye goodbye all right you
[__] threaten me out of here
foreign
I probably am in the wrong but I'm not
gonna have some crackhead yell at me
don't do that right now what the [__]
dude it was a miscommunication I don't
care
I've taken so much [__] from so many
people there's so many that I just
cracked I cracked what's wrong oh he's
in there screaming like a maniac I told
him to screaming at me quit acting like
can I jump over there and thump his ass
I don't even acting like that in there
they've got too much confusion going on
you've got Danny you've got his
girlfriend you've got the mother and
you've got the father and none of them
go to the top floor the elevator don't
go there brother I'm sorry Chef did he
ask you to leave with yes he did he told
me I'm fired
foreign
this is the most [__] up place I've
ever worked at the entire family is
insane they're all crazy I don't know
what to say
David's weapons she threatened me so
he's gonna beat me up so I fired him
he's always this crazy always uh all
right
and this is too rare look at this oh
come on what is this what was this that
was supposed to be all double check the
ticket but I think it's a Somerset Shire
it's supposed to be medium rare come on
guys I'd rather keep them waiting five
minutes for something cooked beautifully
while chaos Reigns in the kitchen not
surprisingly the dining room is a
disaster as well oh my goodness there's
no customers they last
they left caught up and went they
faces are root beer floats how you gave
it to him on the house
when a customer gets up second time
around and walks out and leaves their
food and now it's terrible
Burger Kitchen Burger Massacre
dinner service completely falling apart
Chef David Blaine returns but he hasn't
come back to cook hey Jen you fired me
on his thousand dollar paycheck right
now California law stay you pay me
before you fire me despite my check all
right I don't want this one to bounce
please all right
all right in handball today with nice
checks
are over here and he
because Danny's fired him why did Danny
find him he was right to fire him he's
saying he wants his thousand dollar
check the other ones have bounced do we
have a thousand dollars to pay him you
can't talk to him right okay okay okay
okay
I don't have a thousand dollars right
today but I can pay you tomorrow I
demand my check because I won't come
back here who knows tomorrow if you're
gonna even be here
obviously going to be here that's
obvious and you know that you know what
when I don't know what to her hopefully
you won't be here man I'm telling you
that give me my check and I'll cash it
tomorrow posted it for tomorrow fine you
want me to do it honey okay write a
check for a thousand dollars Jim take 20
bucks out and go buy you a prescription
of Prozac it's not necessary
oh I need to say this please what do you
need to say what do you say did Danny
give you back the money for the produce
you both yes you did why did he give you
back he gave you back 100 I also gave
you 15. well it didn't take 15 out minus
20 for your Prozac
first of all Jen had nothing to do with
what happened Danny did she said about
this sitting between me and Danny at
this point it's not between me you it's
between me and you and then your use and
need a Prozac Now give me my check
foreign
situations over the years
tonight's dinner service might just be
the craziest he has ever seen give me my
check right now I'm not playing David
check please stop please
I'm not on anything he's the one that
needs this so-called Prozac I don't even
know what it does
[Music]
my God is that lady Alan how can you
blame her for something that Danny did
I'm not playing with her I just I'm just
telling her she needs Prozac I'm telling
her the truth
to say that she needs Prozac or anything
like that that's below the belt and it's
disgusting and I've lost all respect for
it I'm not on proof who cares if you're
on the [__] process don't worry about
that Jesus Christ write the check for a
thousand and you can put the money in
tomorrow for us
how the [__] could he put the money no I
don't I don't know
please don't get involved right now
these people will never respect him I'm
just over again and now I'm taking money
they're just [__] up people
you don't have the money in there so I'm
sorry Jesus Christ what
no I have to be legitimate Danny's not
giving you any more money he's already
giving you too much and I'm sorry that's
pissing me it's not your choice Alan
please don't yell at a girl I love it
Alan please don't yell I love it please
go out your Tuesday your choice just
come out it's not Danny's toys either
all right
and she's a young lady please don't yell
in her
you should be
[__] meth heads what a joke honestly
no Marion what's wrong with this one
it's too well done they ordered medium
rare and it's wise in the middle on a
night when 21 dishes are returned
and yet another Chef is fired
Daniel is devastated just
it's really hard you know
that was horrendous yeah you know what I
even got threatened to be beaten up and
all I want to do is [__]
I just want to serve a good burger you
know I mean you're 29 years of age
you've got the well in your shoulders
but God's sake this is crazy you can't
do it you know
it all hit me like a Floodgate I just I
just started crying I couldn't take it
[Music]
come on take over you
wake up take over let's go we're going
under maybe I should just close the
doors I can't do this not this you know
bloody hell God that's
[Music]
safe
next time on a special edition of
Kitchen Nightmares what the [__] is that
will Chef Ramsay be able to convince
Daniel to stay in the business it's a
disaster will the family be able to
resolve their differences
want to miss what happens
when new shocking issues are revealed
you're [__] killing me it's intense
it's outrageous and it's the biggest
challenge Chef Ramsay has faced all year
[Music]
I can't do this I'm sorry it's not fair
buddy it's not fair
[Music]
it's like let's see if we can do crack
tonight
I just want to laugh and I want to cry
because
who are you going through I stand fully
now okay it's a disaster
I've never seen such a fragmented
business oh my God
and the chefs like that they even
friends to beat me up I'm gonna take
that [__] man it's ridiculous I just I
just finally cracked I didn't think this
would happen when he's been warning me
that it's all just being bottled up and
you're just gonna break down
here's the sad news none of this is your
fault and yet you seem to be the only
one taking responsibility the mom and
dad are dreaming you know that I know
I know
feeding their dreams and getting
yourself further and further in the
shape you finally realize what's
happening so you've now got to take the
reins you've got no choice now
you have got to stand up on your own two
feet and not tolerate this [__]
come on come on
I've got your back
because I can see what it means to you
thank you that's all I could say thank
you
for you're the only reason I'm staying
here I'm telling you thank you you don't
like you because you're sincere
you actually can pretty much have a
pretty big heart you do thank you thank
you for this
you know I've never had someone actually
like help you know
thank you
hang on in there okay
[Music]
after witnessing one of the most
dysfunctional restaurants he has ever
seen good morning come in come in please
take a seat Chef Ramsay knows it's time
for a not so subtle wake-up call first
of all I wanted to get you out of the
restaurant that was important yeah thank
you and what better way to do that than
bring you to an amazing little theater
and a little show we all like a show
right believe me this is quite a show
ladies and gentlemen may I present
the yelpers
good morning
wow there's a lot of helpers Chef Ramsay
had the absolute nerve to reach out to
the office they are deliberately
attacking my restaurant wow they're the
actual yelpers every yelpert lies they
hurt and damage restaurants by doing
this okay Alan listen carefully you were
100 convinced that those negative
reviews were part of a conspiracy is
there a plus against you from Yelp to
close this business no question in my
mind Alan there's someone I'd like you
to meet this lady is the community
manager for Yelp Katie Burbank
hi I know that you're very frustrated
but they're all real we're all real all
of our reviews mean something it's
feedback for you to use however you'd
like
hi
um I'm a big Rooter for you guys I am
and I wanted to love your burger so bad
like I love burgers and I didn't came in
because I can spend 26 dollars on an
amazing Burger it uh wasn't amazing I
was expecting an explosion of flavor but
I pretty much didn't taste anything what
I got in the burger was an extremely
unflavorful huge piece of meat that had
the consistency of a nasty loaf of
Meatloaf I absolutely detest what served
at your restaurant I'm not like an avid
yelpert in fact I created the account
just to comment on your place because
that burger was so disappointing in the
end it was a big who smear of a horrible
experience I too signed up for Yelp just
to write a review and it was the one and
only Yelp review we have ever written
interesting that customers are purposely
opening accounts to post a comment wrote
a review I received a response from you
that basically told me I didn't know
what I was talking about and it was
essentially my fault that I had a bad
review I wrote my review on Yelp only to
be met with sort of a barrage of emails
from you and you told me that you
thought we were good competition and you
told me that you thought we were out to
get you at one point you threatened to
turn us over to the hate crime division
of the LAPD instead of saying sorry come
back in I will make it better it was
kind of an attack and to me it felt like
maybe this place is hopeless because
they're not taking the criticism like is
this place doomed
um Jen am I keeping you up darling would
you like a blanket
I was angry at my mom for falling asleep
I don't know what she was trying to pull
there we've been here 10 minutes and I'd
like you to look good but to watch you
sit there and snore I think it's the
height of Bad Manners I was incredibly
frustrated I thought this is not gonna
work
unbelievable I mean unbelievable they're
customers no no no no no you're missing
my point completely this is what's
driving me nuts every single one of
these people here everywhere you you
enough this is ridiculous
have to stop caring about Yelp he's
trying to get you off of this [__] man
I'm missing a point you are so obsessed
with this becoming five stars four stars
no it's an arbitrary number man you're
concerned about this so much and these
people are actually honest they told you
that they have a terrible [__] time
ridiculous you make excuses
[Music]
no no enough
laughs
Chef Ramsay gathered yelpers to prove to
the family and to the staff the real
damage they have caused to their
reputation you were 100 convinced that
those reviews were part of a conspiracy
and to show Alan that this is not a
conspiracy no no no no no you're missing
my point enough enough this is
ridiculous
and these people are
honestly they told you that they have a
terrible [__] time it's ridiculous
you make excuses
no no enough
he didn't blast you he just told you
that you're worrying about the wrong
things
okay there's someone I'd like you to
meet
the owner and the executive chef of The
Foundry on Melrose Eric good morning sir
who's gonna give you a little insights
to how he deals with Yelp
you know one of the things that I think
you always have to be very careful of
when it comes to Yelp is you can't look
at these and take them as personal
attacks them and try to adjust them at
the end of the day it's not personal if
it was personal they come up and tell it
to your face
you know I get one star reviews I get
five star reviews I get the whole board
you know even my my grilled cheese
sandwich everybody says that sandwich
around people real reviews to say it's
the worst sandwich I've ever had what do
I do do I change the grilled cheese no
but if 18 people tell me my burger is
under seasoned 18 of them are telling me
that there's got to be a problem and
it's worth looking at it and like you
said if there's 18 complaints about one
particular item trust me we've got it
wrong so we move and we change course we
take Yelp as an advantage to reposition
ourselves and we listen to a consensus
that's what we do
the only thing I ever get wrong on is I
don't like unfairness I was focused on
that wrongly and I apologize look any
review that you get from somebody is
feedback and if you're too obsessed
about why they're saying it and not what
they're saying you're gonna find
yourself in trouble thank you
Chef Ramsay maybe I'm obsessed and I'm
wrong I agree with you I'll never ever
speak about this again and I appreciate
it enormously because I hope we can
learn from this and improve hopefully
something got through to my dad but he's
stubborn the guy has a gift of blissful
ignorance a gift we have to go back to
directions and we've got a lot to do I
trust you're gonna give us one more go
Burger Kitchen and think of your
patience this morning giving up your day
and to be here thank you so much thank
you very much thank you
thank you
[Music]
okay let's go now that Chef Ramsay has
gotten through to Alan about his
so-called Yelp conspiracy forget it okay
gone gone from my mind we're over Yelp
[Music]
he now moves on to a much bigger problem
of the restaurant there's something else
that I need to talk to you all about
there is so much tension in this
restaurant from this family it is
extraordinary and the only way this
business can move forward is if we clear
the air
first of all who runs the restaurant
who's in charge of the restaurant really
by default it seems that I am I don't
want to be
serious
hey what are you full control
exactly what I'm saying wind is a
[__] higher
let me ask you this thing do not trust
Daniel I I trust him 100 percent
of course Whitney believes I don't
why don't you trust your father what is
the one big reason that you don't trust
him
trust you because of how you opened this
restaurant
I put in 250 000 you put in 250 000
that's a total of five hundred thousand
dad I never put 250
000 into this
so you didn't give permission from your
father to
sort of look after no no no no no no
never I want to be on the paperwork I
want evidence of how much I actually own
that's why I put it with the account
well just always the same excuse you
know maybe we need a new accountant
Danny is getting taken advantage of and
he's being worked his ass off and he's
not even given a chance to even like
feel bad excuse me Wendy you don't have
a right to be cruel I
register and then they say they repay
themselves
a constant thing you're alive
I thought about giving him anything for
the money
don't you dare lie to me wait wait
that's because you're taking it all stop
attacking an outright liar enough
[Music]
you get paid he doesn't you're a liar
Chef Ramsay has called a family meeting
to clear the air have you ever thought
about giving him anything for the money
you idiot but it's quickly turned into a
battle between Daniel and Wendy you know
what that's
at all and Allen and Jen you're an
outright liar wait wait
listen to yourself this is someone I
love very much and the way you treat her
is like [__] and as long as you and Dad
I didn't like her and Wendy as long as
you dislike them this will never ever
ever
Daniel what do you want no seriously
what do you want
that's a very good question what does
Daniel want yeah what do you want no
seriously what do you want
I want you guys to stop like making
excuses and and going back on lies and
and trying to win you don't need to win
you know you don't need to be right all
the goddamn time all you have to admit
is that you know all you have to admit
is that what you did was wrong what you
did was really really wrong just like
Danny Danny go shut up shut up
I live in this like depressed [__]
world you know and all three of you on
the side of this killing me man you're
[__] killing me you know you really
are you really really are
[Music]
all right
I cannot do anymore
okay I'm not okay I just want I just I'm
asking for like a week a day
I want to know what you want what do you
want to guess what if you get along
I can't get along with her
you can't get along with it no I can't
so for the sake of the family and the
potential business can you just give him
that do you not deserve that now
how do I do that when I and I don't
believe in that how do I you're asking
me how you get it I'll be civilized
don't fight and just learn to walk away
we're in a dreadful predicament and it's
faster than got so much worse and it's
so sad to see a family ripped apart with
the viciousness it is not necessary
you have to change your ways both of you
I got told to get back and read this on
my book
Euro book yeah gentle Satan it was about
my father that's what my mother called
him I stayed up to four o'clock this
morning because it's almost like I was
living it live yeah I was seeing a
reenact of the same scenario
I mean let me read you a few uh extracts
he hated being called out on his
behavior especially by his son
I was caught in a tug of war between my
mother and father
does this sound familiar yes
he didn't listen to anyone else's
opinion and he did as he chose
in his business ventures
[Music]
too and I'm sorry to tell you this but
you've got to listen it's a sequel but
it's live and it's going on in these
four walls yes it is
like father like son
[Music]
I see exactly what Chef Ramsey has
brought up I mean it
I was wrong
it's irrelevant
of everything else
but I apologize to both of you
with all of my heart I have done the
wrong thing if we can't get together we
might as well just close the door now
[Music]
that's the smartest thing you've said
since I've been through these doors we
need to draw a line in the sand forgive
and forget and move forward and that's
exactly what Daniel's asked you to do I
will do my best
forget the business the most important
thing in life is family
now maybe we can begin yeah and moving
forward and focus on the restrooms okay
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you
it's hard for a father to do that to
admit to a son that he made a terrible
mistake and I admitted it I want to
freeze this moment because it's the
first actually like time that you three
of you have actually gotten along for
more than like 15 seconds Timmy listen
to me I swear on my life I meant every
last word every last word of what I mean
I believe it there is no question in my
mind
this day should have happened long ago
after what appears to be a major
breakthrough with the family Chef Ramsay
can finally turn his attention to the
food we'll go through and train okay so
we know how to cook a burger okay
[Music]
let's throw a new classic burger first
of all a nice season lightly brush oil
and the nice exciting thing about these
Burgers it's freshly ground meat 15 fat
so they're full of flavor something your
Frozen burgers were lacking guys I want
you guys to learn everything I feel like
I'm learning a lot watching Chef Ramsay
medium rare medium and well done it's
going to take all of that information
and run the restaurant as best as I can
on top and then back
okay let's go
[Music]
okay ladies take a slice and dig in
the new blend of the special burger with
Chef Ramsay's touch that's very nice
it's a pretty Fabulous Burger this is
amazing wow so good
this is amazing price good too the
burger that we had was way better than
our old Frozen patties That's a classic
burger put on the special in place of
the classic tonight but that's just the
first step we have a million more miles
to walk I know it's just a small change
but it's in the right direction okay
classic burger
the mood is already different for
tonight's dinner service to stay intense
with the specials Daniel is clearly
inspired hey Chef okay bye Chef Ramsay
really one person Expediting Daniel okay
you give an answer yes chef yes yes it
made me feel great when uh Chef Ramsay
seemed to have the confidence in me to
run things but I really really hope that
my parents step aside
welcome to Burger Kitchen okay we are
running a special tonight we're doing a
new ground chuck steak blend burner and
then it also comes with fries I'm gonna
try the specials the special please it's
true the classic specials yeah okay
order up two specials right now and then
our regular stuff a California and an
iPhone let's get those onion rings out
now
thank you
played all those fries for the special
right now we got three going out perfect
you're about to see a [__] miracle
took some work come on let's go first
first classic South they wanted medium
rare yeah yeah thanks to Daniel's
leadership in the kitchen food is making
its way out to the dining room it's
special
and while Chef Ramsay's special is a hit
the old menu are getting the same old
complaints
videos are too spicy No One's Gonna put
that in their mouth huh all the time we
served like that I know but we ought to
embrace change now man yeah gotta change
gotta change okay jalapeno I'm gonna
need you to drop sweet potato fries
regular fries what hasn't been made
because there's lots of [__] sides oh
my God we have no Organization no system
everything just became a [__]
again
did you get those onion rings to table
12 ever
hello I hope so I'd put them out you put
them out uh let me see it this system is
so [__] up dude so too sweet one fried
no one sweet two fry one potato skin one
onion ring there we go let's get back on
track right now okay onion rings good I
need oh perfect well Daniel is on his
way to reorganizing the kitchen where's
those onion rings onion rings on the fly
please you just repeated exactly what I
said Alan feels the need to step in and
help stay at your position I am today is
your position
my dad keeps going back to that same old
thing where's the the confidence I want
to be confident okay we're missing onion
rings for table 12. he's dead he's
stubborn and he's unwilling to change
it's very infuriating can you pick these
two burgers
42. okay table um 42 has been waiting
for a very long time just setting their
owner out if he continues to come back
here and ask for onion rings or whatnot
I'm done he needs feedback but just
rather than go in there they've been
waiting how long 24 it's just gone just
interesting for each other you know okay
I understand so going in there and
dropping negatives off the negatives up
and then I'm trying I really after this
I never I need to try it a different way
it's your son he's not your Chef he's
your son servers servers Chef Ramsay is
right like father like son
doing a great job we're getting out much
faster than we were last night
I gotta stop it right now
said Son to be like me and in turn pass
it on to his child
with Allen taking a back seat that's it
that's it that's all
[Music]
Daniel pushes the last orders out thank
you very much for coming thank you thank
you welcome
let me say one thing at least that was
better than last night yeah and from
last night yeah
um was I proud of tonight no there's
still a lot that we need to improve I
agree but you know what that's a great
position for you in there because you're
in control and you sound and look like
an owner okay good job thank you thank
you tomorrow we are saying goodbye to
the past and we are relaunching this
restaurant I got some serious work to do
good night I'll see you in the morning
thank you Sean okay thank you good night
chef
after a draining few days Chef Ramsay's
crew Works through the night to
transform this non-descript restaurant
into a trendy La Hangout
[Music]
let's go good morning hi good morning
let's be honest yesterday we clearly
took a big turn for the good today is
about saying goodbye to the past and
open the door so the new chapter of the
Burger Kitchen let's go let's go let's
go let's go
whoa
it's unbelievable welcome to the new
Burger Kitchen
let's start off with those amazing new
murals on the wall look at them no more
ugly green Walls no more ugly green
Walls
the atmosphere beforehand was so
depressing unbelievable now we have pop
art they're hip they're cool and they're
very trendy incredible this is
unbelievable oh my God no more booths
this is incredible Danny over here is a
chalkboard where we can go and have some
fun on there we are only as good as our
last Burger it's interactive you can
leave messages that you can recommend
wow wow wow wow it's unbelievable I'm
sorry I am I am I'm very I it just it
looks great I honestly feel that this
place has urban street appeal I sound
like a tool saying that but that's the
industry you have to look hip and you
have to look cool do you feel like you
can bring your girlfriends now finally
yeah finally I feel like happy to work
here it no longer looks like tacky
cheese ball 80s disgustingness it looks
like a trendy cool restaurant so in
keeping with the trendy dining room I
want to introduce issue to a very cool
state of the heart unique point of sale
system this thing is extraordinary oh my
God it's provided by Zephyr hardware and
it is POS lava it is incredible ladies
you're at the table
with your wireless touch screen device
oh my god wow that's how you place the
order you just press but it comes up in
front of them and the kitchen gets
information running around with the
tickets stressing out to hell what in
the [__] are all these tickets here this
is ridiculous this game of Solitaire
I could swipe credit cards inventory can
be checked out against your purchasing
you bring in the beers it gets entered
in and you get a daily stop take
unbelievable you should monitor it from
your wireless computer anywhere in the
world and no one in your area has this
wow
wow wow I can't thank you enough I
really can't I can't thank you enough
man this is
[Music]
your eyes Alan you okay yeah yeah you're
sure fantastic why is this one is alive
in the place up a little bit and bring
some some excitement in here with that
depressing green Wall come on ah it's
incredible it was nice to see if my Dow
shows some emotion it was he genuinely
seemed happy he really actually seemed
happy this is incredible this is a
hundred 1000 times better
I just can't wait for people to walk in
the door
now that Burger Kitchen has a cool new
look Chef Ramsay has come up with a menu
to match I take your menu parcel along
please have a look at menu number 23
everybody it is so nice it's a keeper it
looks great it's small it's Dynamic and
more importantly it is delicious wow
right here we go nibbles okay we have
sweet potato fries all natural fries
parmesan fries and they are hand cut
delicious next up we have a vodka
battered onion rings delicious for the
table vodka batter wow that's a that's a
damn good idea way to taste them Burgers
start off with the classic America we
got that amazing Pate 15 fat short rib
chuck and a 10 dry age just to keep you
quiet so it's good I like not touch that
recipe let me tell you no it's a great
recipe oh my God if he touches it keep
your paws off it oh put your right hand
up bye Alan will not change the Pate I
Alan swear to God I will change nothing
excellent yes yes finally okay we've got
the most amazing Glam Burger delicious
low in fat and this one's done with a
really classic tzatziki sauce next to
that a western beef patty sharp cheddar
delicious fried onion rings and that's
so with a very rich homemade barbecue
sauce I love this I love this Asian
persuasion yes Asian style beef Pate
Cherokee glaze with a delicious Asian
slaw can we eat I want to eat I want to
try this food put your knife and forks
dive in and enjoy
freaking bomb those are bomb out of
control again wow
you'd be stupid to think it's not good
it's fabulous
oh God just come running here
immediately it's one of the best burgers
I've ever tasted in my life it's
Sensational I will never need to change
the menu again
[Music]
clearly Burger Kitchen now has something
it never had a sense of hope okay ready
the Chef Ramsay has some important news
to share with the staff
[__] week and as you all know we've been
through some major changes and we have
made a significant a significant step in
the right direction
do you know that in a year and a half
this restaurant managed to sort of
self-inflict its dwindling reputation
but tonight you have a big second chance
it's not only relaunch night
but I have filled this restaurant with
[Music]
it's relaunch night at the Burger
Kitchen tonight you have a second chance
and the pressure is already on but Chef
Ramsay has some important information to
share it's not only relaunch night but I
have filled this restaurant
with serious bloggers
coming to dine tonight
yeah
tasting table ciao Urban Spoon Serious
Eats LA and Blackboard eats this is the
night can transform this business all or
nothing there's no rehearsal so get real
and get a grip we are now getting
together an enormous amount of critics
all in one night we deliver we're set
for life we cannot screw up at all
Daniel yes anything you want to say to
the team here's how it's going to work
tonight dad you're going to be behind
the bar don't host Tonight
I'll be Expediting Mom you can host
tonight
good luck everybody let's go do this
guys come on let's do this all right
[Music]
you guys ready make me proud Hi how are
you welcome to Burger Kitchen
thank you for coming brand new redesign
new menu I'm sure you'll have a great
time California already how would you
like your cook [__]
I can't even believe this is the same
restaurant
I know right finally the new POS is
fantastic makes me happy it's gonna make
me more positive when I see tables
we have got to step up tonight we got a
Juicy Lucy well we need to just focus on
what I told everyone to do first oh
they're ready and if they do that I
think we'll be doing great find slime
start taking them come back just come
back one by one the kitchen is off to a
fast start it was for you and the Divine
swine and burgers are making their way
out to the diners wow this is so good
promising
there's your classic there's your
Western comeback for your sauces then
come back for your pork and even though
Daniel has the kitchen running smoothly
excuse me Danny what we are missing
Canyon rings and house pickles at the
bar okay you heard that onion rings and
house pickles for the bar Allen has left
his post at the bar and his back where
he is not wanted 31 brownies tell their
onion rings together all the way Dad
please
please move Daniel want to meet just
behind the bar the bottom line is you
can't stop me going to mingle with the
customers how's everything over here
okay okay very good thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you I'm an
owner I'm not a vegetable I was going to
get you another helping someone said you
were still hungry
comes over don't worry about it
dad I I'm gonna range
behind the bar please okay
bothering tables and he gets in the way
and it's too much how is the order
coming from you behind the bar behind
the bar for this place to succeed Alan
needs to go are you sure 31. it's got
one at 31. bring it back bring it back
with me ice cream cookie you got it
Danny okay this is question number 31
there's no one at 31. there's a 31
that's 31 there for four gentlemen
totally messed things up there's no 31
that's 31. oh not to go near this system
go near it okay fine Julia didn't
understand we're not gonna worry about
it stay at the bar okay
Daniel is now focused on his father
instead of the kitchen
where's done
Wells order is that coming up well we
don't even have a 12. and unsupervised
burgers are making their way out to
influential bloggers where is uh where's
Daniel don't come over here
I have to come over to get beer this is
a huge night for us and my dad is
driving me crazy right now if he
continues to get us all off our game
then it's really really bad
let me have him fix this one then
[Music]
sorry yeah what do we got this is too
rare oh look at this come on guys
look what you do to us it's raw
[__]
is the sun down and focus
[Music]
it's relaunch night at the Burger
Kitchen and while Daniel's attention is
diverted to his father stick to the plan
where's done food is still managing to
go out
but unfortunately without Daniel's
quality control a burger is coming back
this is too rare oh
on guys
doing to us it's raw slow down
absolutely
keeping behind the [__] bar yeah
please go away Dad please okay fine your
dad's so dead set in his way he's not
doing any benefit but causing Mayhem
and it's irrelevant when you're
Expediting you're at the helm what we
did to Dad is exactly we've got to do
more of and I've kind of triggered
something in me and I said you know what
Chef Ramsay is very very talented he
believes in me yeah we find that classic
America medium rare 43. I really have to
take the reins the only way the place is
going to work I need that forking Asian
as fast as possible
jalapeno for 43 I need my fries my chips
and my fried pickles and his father
entrenched at the bar orders are
correctly making their way to the hungry
critics here we go so
yeah
and the dining room is full of rave
reviews
[Music]
so tonight we took a major step forward
let me tell you that and the Burger
Kitchen is on his way this restaurant
can work
but
we cannot afford to go back
to our old ways and the minute we do
we're screws
[Music]
Daniel has proven to me he has the
capabilities of running this place he's
amazing thank you Chef let him do it
with all due respect
this is Daniel's Restaurant to run
and there can only be one leader
you cannot interfere and intervene I
will not promise
I promise
my son always made a good impression
with people but Chef Ramsay saw more
than that and more than even I saw that
my son could lead and run a restaurant
I'm sorry but this is the best advice
okay
I can give you
all I want to say is this I am thankful
to you well I'm grateful everything
that's happened because now I feel like
we've got a makings of a success and I
give it to my son with the greatest joy
wow thank you and I know your heart's in
the right place wow Chef Ramsay is right
I know that my son can handle it after
watching him in the relaunch of our new
restaurant that was a job well done
would you mind if I have a two-minute
conversation with Daniel please yes of
course thank you very much look after
yourself
[Music]
okay
a few words of advice yeah my father
died at 53.
I think get chance to say what I needed
to say and make up with him before he
passed away
you
may never forget what he did to you
but you have to forgive him and you have
to move on yeah okay don't forget I
won't I won't but forgive okay yes yes
make sense absolutely absolutely I'll do
that I believe in you
and I I I know I know wow you can't make
this a success good luck it felt really
good it's every single emotion you would
feel when someone of that caliber you
know puts that on you and says you can
do it thank you thank you thank you
thank you
[Music]
and as I've ever done Daniel may have
been dragged into the business but right
now he's the only one who can save it he
has all the tools to make it work it
just needs to be left alone to do it
22 menus
wow what a week
after Chef Ramsay left there you go guys
enjoy Alan and Jen kept the promise and
left the business in Daniel's hands
Danny is in charge I am passing the rain
100 to him under Daniel's leadership
Maryland running to 21 jalapeno turkey
Divine swine the Burger Kitchen is
generating a ton of positive buzz in the
neighborhood as the go-to place for an
awesome Burger
everything all made in-house Chef Ramsay
did more than anyone could ask for he's
saving his restaurant and he'd save the
relationship I have with my family
foreign